[Music]
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host on sockin very excited and also one
of the most important topics that we can
be talking about challenging perverse
incentives in science we have dr. Lewis
Metzger joining us on the show hello hi
thanks for having me yes for round
number two and the first time we talked
about your company here at Biosciences
cell-free Molecular discovery that links
in the bio for you guys to check out
episode one with Lewis also at the very
top of the bio you will find lewis's
medium article that he wrote that
article is about a scandal that occurred
at Duke where the foundation of
scientific truth was being at it was at
risk and at harm and being maliciously
the perverse incentives were at play and
Lewis wrote a very detailed article
about on medium about the entire story
and you can check that out too the first
link again go and check that out for the
bid for the detail Lewis and I will be
spending this episode talking about how
to challenge these perverse incentives
in the scientific system so Lewis let's
let's start things off with this
importance of father foundation of
science you know your new think-tank bio
captivate is really also focus on these
new incentive systems in our social
fabric to make the foundation of science
really powerfully robust and true and
just impenetrable by these perverse
incentives so teach us about your
thoughts around this so you know part of
this is is really a discussion of the
culture of science and like all cultures
there's heterogeneity in it and it
shifts around but I think that in terms
of incentivizing science we need to
think as science as a whole and what
it's trying to accomplish so science is
really a collective endeavor and I think
when one looks at Nobel prizes
and publication records and and how
scientists are often recognized and
rewarded that recognition is usually
individualistic and I think to build
strong science it's really teamwork it's
a collectivism and it would be nice to
to recognize scientists as large groups
who've accomplished large things rather
than individuals who've accomplished
large things with a great deal of help
and and so you know my article about the
Lingga scandal is full of technical
detail it's full of some interpersonal
detail but I think one of the themes
that comes out of it is why do people do
science and and how how can we make
science incentivized to be reproducible
and and one of those things is
conceiving of science as a building so
you want your foundations to be strong
you don't want them to be built on sand
and and every small piece of science
every every paper every piece of data
that goes into a published paper is part
of that foundation and and we're really
building a scientist we're building the
architecture of something that we can't
we don't know what it's going to look
like when we're finished but what we can
do is make sure that the parts that we
build are solid and can be reproduced
and I think that if there are any
lessons to take away from many of these
scientific misconduct scandals it's the
it's the price that's paid by everyone
not just scientists but you know
taxpayers businesses the whole community
when parts of the edifice that they're
building is built on you know unsteady
foundations yes yes this view of the
foundation of science being what has
really driven so much of society's
success over the period of the
Industrial Revolution until today that
if with without really our ability to
build robustly on top of this scientific
foundation we wouldn't have all these
incredible luxuries that we have today
that were so privileged
with and so when you let little tiny
parasites in with this perverse system
of prioritizing money over prioritizing
science and so many other things that
were we're harming our ability to
innovate we're harming our one of our
only things that we can call objectively
true these reproducible scientific
experiments that give us a better real
understanding of the world that we live
in and you know I think for your viewers
who don't know how the scientific
publishing process works in general and
there are some exceptions there's
usually a premium put on novelty of the
research and if in the course of doing
one we doing ones research and
publishing it one repeats parts of
someone else's research that's good but
the novelty and the recognition for that
novelty is are what drives the
publication and review process in most
cases the first being the first and it's
great to be the first there's nothing
wrong with it and should of course be
encouraged we need people to push the
boundaries but I think we need to find
ways as a society and and more
specifically in the scientific community
to recognize people who reproduce
science or who go the extra mile to make
sure that they're published science is
minutely reproducible and I think if you
look back in history when scientific
publication involved the trading of
letters between amateur scientists there
was a much greater emphasis on passing
the baton so one person picking up the
other's work and being able to continue
it and so there was an incentive ization
with one correspondence to build
something that that could be could be
expanded and I think that in our rush to
to value priority these days you know we
were not incentivizing the right thing
and and and if you look what what what
who Linga appears to have done at what
helena appears to have done if you look
at a large body of proven and alleged
research misconduct in science it's
largely in the pursuit of that priority
status
yes and this would probably be a good
time for you to teach us about the the
sheer emotional state and that you were
feeling because you know if this is a la
ronde 11 years ago there is just just
this overwhelming feeling that that
graduate students postdocs just have
such a power asymmetry two professors
and Dean's they can't vocalize that
there's this massive issue with the
foundation of science happening and it's
just overwhelmingly discouraging when
this sitting on their royal throne this
this gated institutional narrative of
ivory tower and you can't take me off of
ten year where I'm getting the $250,000
a year professor ship position and and
teach us about what was actually you
know going through you at that at that
time well so so it's interesting the the
culture of advanced research in
biological sciences and and physics and
chemistry is often one of isolation so
as a student or as a postdoctoral
researcher one usually works on one's
own project sometimes it's collaborative
but it's a relatively isolating
experience and long days spent in the
lab your closest friends or at least you
know cohort daily cohort are is
comprised of the people who happen to
work with you and and that can be
friends well yeah yeah usually not
inanimate objects although I must say
sometimes it felt that way but but and
then communities do are built but it's
generally isolating and so if you think
of that isolation but then you also
think of a perverse incentive and I
alluded to it when we last spoke but I
can go into more detail now I think it
should be understood that the model of
big research universities is to harvest
government grants and private foundation
grants and and those grants are awarded
to faculty members professors who apply
to those grants using data that
they're postdoctoral scholars and their
graduate students and their technicians
produce and and you know those grants
are assessed for their novelty usually
and are they second checking of the data
making reproduce the review process for
grants is very brief and most of the
time the proposals are viewed only in a
cursory manner by most of the committee
members so it's it's not as rigorous of
a process as people might think I think
we need it because and as we need it to
be but I think more importantly it
encourages the training of more and more
graduate students more and more postdocs
because this is a bit of a pyramid
scheme so you need these laborers who
are getting an education it is true to
in it to a point to generate data which
the professor uses to publish papers
which help get grants but then those
grants are usually when received the
money is sliced into two parts and often
for universities like Duke and and UCSF
and you know many big schools have taken
a hundred percent off the top so they
take half of the grant money to keep the
lights on and surely that money goes to
keeping the lights on in part but where
you've seen in the last you know two or
three decades is this huge proliferation
of Dean's and and and administration
because all this money is getting sliced
off the top of these these government
grants but it causes this feedback loop
and and it really incentivizes
universities to become paper mills and
and this I don't think is always
consistent with good science and
reproducible science because the
incentive is really to generate money
using this pyramid scheme of trainees
and I would hasten to say that
individual professors don't really have
the option of opting out of the system
yeah now they can mitigate it but I
wouldn't say that the system is anyone's
design but it's evolved into what it it
is now and I think we should we should
look at changing that so that's a major
perverse incentive that is a subtext of
the whole Hullinger story which your
viewers can read about in detail
oh man it just that makes me feel like
the the administration is becoming like
bloated oh yeah and and it's becoming
like a parasite on the actual scientific
foundation because these administrator
roles how often are they actually really
powerful mentorship or industry related
connection roles you know the things
that actually advance the scientific
edge forward and that's what we need be
thinking about you are also explaining
the the mentality that you know getting
all these grad students and getting all
the all the postdocs so that you can
make more data because with the data
then you can make more papers and then
you can get more money and that's this
whole cycle of we are stressing people
out to make data instead of being like
creatively explore the edge of science
and let's figure out a better way to
funnel the money in for that and and and
another part of this is education so
readers people who read about the Lingga
article I wrote and the scandal that it
discusses might think a bit about
education and and and universities
responsibility for educating people
because I will say in science graduate
training it's a mixture of training and
education and one could you know could
quibble about how much of each but in
the end there is ostensibly education
going on and for me that education was
real because I had a conscientious
thesis advisor yeah who really stood by
me and and I was fortunate in that
regard but I think that universities
exist in a privileged place in society
is in Western society by tradition
because they evolved from these these
it's the endowment eight and a half
billion eight and a half billion at Duke
but Harvard's is far larger harvests
like 30 billion tens of billions of
billions so so so lots of money in this
and in you know in ancient times
universities were you know had a
clerical nature to them in the Western
traditions so you know they were
offshoots of the Catholic Church to an
extent and had always existed outside of
the normal
their laws so basically they got a pass
on regulation and even in these modern
times in a secular country we still have
echoes of that privilege because if
businesses behaved the way universities
get away with yeah yeah they would be in
great regulatory trouble so the way I
see it is one can't have it both ways
one can't one can't get a pass on
regulation and act as a money harvesting
business so I strongly think that we
should go back to in some way or another
a focus on education the privilege that
providing that education gives to
universities and also the
responsibilities entailed in that
privilege yeah yeah and this is a very
interesting point so many people talk
about the regulations and the laws that
go with having to work with the FDA or
whatever it may be in order to get your
get your business to be able to produce
the product or service that it wants to
make but when there's this this these
perverse incentives that are occurring
in something that is you're you're
taking us through a historical
transition of the university system
becoming what it is now in the United
States that where are the where are the
rent seekers how can we identify the
rent seekers the the ones that are
siphoning away money from the foundation
of scientific truth for their own
perverse incentives and how can we just
you know really start shattering those
perverse incentives and do we need in
this do we need more like industry
involved do we need
you know partly unlike the just the
spiritual awakening of the professors
and the and the universities and the
grant system what is what's our best
case to target this well it's a heart
it's a difficult question to answer and
it's such a multi-faceted problem that
there are probably many approaches I for
one believe that there should be
stronger government regulation of
universities in the US and you know I
don't I don't think it should be
stifling but I think that it should
require adherence to certain standards
in both treatment of students and
postdoctoral fellows you know with a
level of protection and recourse to
recourse to refereed disputes between
researchers and mentor and mentee I also
think that it should provide a better
accounting of what the overhead money
that sliced off the tops of all of these
research grants is used for yes and I
think that with transparency in that
regard it might still be taken but it
can be used for probably activities and
purposes for which it was better
intended yeah yeah that's a big one
transparency is huge even in just
something as simple as where are you
this is all the taxpayer dollars this is
what is all out of the main like mine
box because it's just like this is
taxpayer dollars this could be going
towards the scientific advancements that
we need to eradicate poverty these are
the things that that we want to tackle
with scientific advancement and not the
yeah of the other crap I want to just
couple things that I want you to teach
us as well because this is important
this is these these perverse incentives
are still happening parasitically on the
scientific foundation so the people that
are sometimes like in the shoes of the
18 of you that had to like co-sign the
petition and petition dis forward there
are people that are in New York and
speak up and so the the idea of
highlighting whistleblowers and helping
them with a voice what do you recommend
for people that may currently be in
those shoes well what I would recommend
is find colleagues find your community
do this together in part because so many
of our faculty were so spineless in my
old Department of Duke biochemistry not
all of them but many of them just
because of that the students I think
were drawn quite a bit closer to each
other the students and postdocs all the
trainees and I think it was it was
in response to a difficult environment
but in a way it was it was fortunate
because it brought us together at a time
that we thought we could make a
difference and we knew there were some
safety in numbers and I think that this
idea of fostering community and and to
be clearer I think it shouldn't just be
you know whistle blower shouldn't just
look for community among similar types
of trainees even among scientists they
need to build their network and their
friendships outside of the laboratory
with people who have perspectives in
different fields and I think that that's
something in the culture of science that
needs to be done more there's a city of
thought this diversity of thought
diversity of friends and network and
I'll admit that for many years of my
life I was not too good at that and so
so build your community would be my
advice and my other piece of advice
would be be sure that what you're doing
is something that it's a battle that you
have to win or you want to try to win
because you know the pressures applied
can be significant as As Seen you know
as your viewers can read about and in
the end I'm I can't speak for all the
other signers but I would guess that
most of us would not have done anything
differently despite you know despite the
what came of it
and what didn't come of it I I think
would have done the same thing again but
it's lonely and in particular when you
have this huge asymmetry between the
power of the faculty and the ease with
which graduate students and post
doctoral fellows can be dismissed and
one thing that isn't talked about much
and didn't really play into the whole
Inga scandal but but is often a feature
of other scientific misconduct is that
many of our our scientists especially
postdoctoral scholars are here on work
visas with their families and so when
they're dismissed from their positions
they have to leave the country in short
order so think of think of what
asymmetry of power with that that that
that hangs
/ people in those positions and how how
hard they can be made to work and for
how how much they are disincentivized to
- whistle blows because it's they and
their family getting kicked out of the
country so something to think about wow
that's a really important one to have
highlighted as well these power
asymmetries in general in our social
fabric have caused in many ways the
prioritization of shareholders instead
of inclusive stake holding yeah all
these different types of ways that we're
updating the code we have these new code
deployments that need to be happening
and one of the main ones is - the
foundation of science now there are
alternatives also that you know you you
and bio captivate spend so much time
discussing exactly what is the best ways
to tackle this this diversity of thought
especially in science working with
artists working with entrepreneurs
turning scientists into entrepreneurs
like attendee bio you know Khan Academy
and Minerva schools there are these you
listed off all these great alternative
examples to this kind of times this
drudgery that sometimes feels like the
graduate school postdoc asymmetry of
power so tell us about these these
examples of alternatives well
these alternatives are experiments to be
clear and I think that they will
complement what's already done in some
cases replace you know the Minerva
project is is a great example the
Minerva University its first classes
graduating this may if it's a four-year
baccalaureate program but the students
are trained they're undergraduates are
educated in a way very different than
most for your universities and there's
really a focus on thinking thinking and
the study of philosophy early on and
then the study of data and how it can be
manipulated how it can be used and
misused and then after that the students
build upon this foundation and
specialize and I think it's quite a bit
different than many undergraduate
programs I think it it interestingly
enough has some similar
- really ancient educational programs in
the Western tradition at least and it
will be interesting to see where that
goes Indy bio and incubators tech
incubators and accelerators like it are
I think poised to really expand to
really incubate more companies as I
think the nest next Industrial
Revolution is going to be the biology
revolution yes the synthetic biology
revolution and there's so much work to
be done there's a great deal of work and
I think that trainees and academia
graduate students postdoctoral fellows
are beginning to see you don't have to
spend eight years as a postdoc and maybe
get a junior faculty position and maybe
get tenure you know many years after
that or not there are other avenues and
you know one of those avenues is start a
company even if it fails maybe
especially if it fails you've learned
something and so building these serial
biological entrepreneurs out of people
who have been trained in the academic
tradition I think is really good and
might it might serve as sort of a
release valve so help drain this excess
of grad students and postdocs yes out of
universities where they're getting
underpaid and and and mostly
underappreciated and into a place where
they have Alishan and they can make the
most of their creativity and yeah some
will succeed in some will fail but if it
were me I would rather take my chances
on that and so the folks at Indy bio are
really enhance you know advancing that
cause so you know Khan Academy is
another example so someone with an
internet connection can go learn you
know fairly advanced topics at their own
pace on the Internet
and is it the same as standing in a
classroom with someone maybe not quite
but for a big 300 person you know giant
auditorium
you know physics 101 or biology 101 I
think that many of the times in many
instances Khan Academy's classes are
superior and so this idea of Dammam
appetizing learning and just putting it
in the hands of people who may not be
able to afford to pay you know a
thousand dollars a credit hour but they
have a computer and an internet
connection and so I think all these
things are shifting the ground on which
these ivory towers are built and they're
going to have to remodel and adapt yeah
it will be interesting to see if they
can adapt and remodel or if they're all
if those old maps will be obsolete in a
way and the new maps of running these
experiments and education from eighteen
until until twenty eight as potentially
running these little permutations of
ideas to to bring into reality
especially in the synthetic biology
explosion I'm totally in agreeance with
you that we should try more of these
permutations in the field there's also a
very important this it's like it's an
ethos it's an ethos of behind the groove
is what we were talking about our our
friends are working on a project called
behind the groove where they're
highlighting who else in addition to the
star of music is actually making the
music happen the audio engineers the
video the the all the people that put
hard work and time and to be able to
market and sell and all this kind of
stuff that is unseen so same thing in
science the same thing in industry is
that you have large companies where you
only know the top three co-founders of
the company you don't know the other
hundred or more people that make it
happen in science when you have your lab
where you have your professor ship that
you that usually don't know that the
whole grad students and postdocs that
are doing a lot of the hard work so
making a stronger culture of rewarding
the people that are behind the groove in
science that are pushing along and this
is a big thing in like Nobel Prizes as
well as uplifting all of those that
helped you achieve it
well yeah as much good as the Nobel
Prize has done in its history especially
for lifting out of obscurity people who
made these brilliant contributions that
no one else was going to make at that
time despite that being a great thing
I'd like to see an alternative to Nobel
Prizes and I'd like to see team based
prizes yes that reach back along lines
of publications and reach back so all
the people in a trail of research that
leads to some striking and game-changing
discovery it's great now I mean it would
be hard to do it would require almost
the blockchain of science to track but
that's coming that's definite yes yes
and and I think that that would be more
fair because certainly the leaders of
many research programs maybe do deserve
the bulk of the credit in some cases not
all cases some cases but I think that
there's many others where there they've
built the conditions for the science to
flourish and then they're harvesting the
gains and and getting the accolades and
if you look at the really ethical people
among faculty you'll see they're the
ones who are quick to share the credit
with the people yeah who really did the
work with them and it ought to be more
common and there ought to be ways where
we can't incentivize it and and that's
that's why that's one of the hardest
things about moving from academia to
industry is going from I'm an individual
contributor I'm counting the number of
papers that I'm the first author on
where I'm the corresponding author on
and then you move to industry and you're
mostly the author middle author of you
know 50 people on the occasional paper
that the legal department clears you to
publish and that's fine that's good
that's okay but it's a it's a frameshift
in in thinking and a frame shift in how
we we speak about and think about and
value ourselves so and and I think I
think science is a team endeavor yes
there's a lot of people who talk about
it but there should be less talk and
more practice yes
yes I love I love the the the faster
that someone gives credit to other
people that were involved with what they
were doing the more it's authentic yeah
yeah unless it's ego driven science
should not be ego-driven sciences
collective driven year this these these
advancements in science are coming
through you they're not coming for you
they're coming for civilization to
advance on yeah that's a really
interesting I like that imagery you know
a principal investigator as a conduit
rather than you know the destination of
good science and so yeah that's great I
like that can I borrow that we cannot
afford yeah all ideas are no one's yeah
they're they belong to all that is
interesting now I think another
important thing that we should talk
about is the notion of a of a growing
pie as well the positive sum game
instead of the zero-sum game so there's
there's a the edge of knowledge is
constantly being pushed and it's growing
and it's expanding and there's more and
more cool things you just mentioned
blockchain ten years ago no one was
really talking about it now everyone's
talking about it
so there's more and more cool ways to
add things to the scientific foundation
and now this team sport these incentive
systems are more important than ever
tell us both about the expanding
positive sum game as well as some of
your favorite new incentives that we
should start applying to this yeah so
shifting shifting towards what is a
positive sum game and how do we
incentivize it I think the sharing of
credit the sharing of ownership is
really important even if it's small
wedges of ownership yeah
in scientific discoveries that are then
commercialized that that should be
spread around liberally because the the
people who have built the infrastructure
or the project that has led to whatever
intellectual property whatever trade
secrets have some commercial value they
need to share in that and I think that
another another way to to go about
incentivizing
this is this positive sum game is really
to get people thinking about it earlier
and this involves the stories we tell
children this involves this involves the
public sphere this is this is outside of
the Academy this is you know this is in
how how science interacts with the
general public and how scientists
portray themselves and think of all the
movies you've seen where there's
scientific protagonists of one sort or
another when they're not when they're
not portrayed as as eccentric deranged
sorts that are you know Manto maniacally
pursuing some some dangerous project
doctor exactly exactly when they're not
dr. evil they are doing something heroic
and and usually individually heroic or
at most with a small group and I don't
want to see any more of those stories
and I want to see the stories of how the
human genome project went and chainable
and the big projects that are going on
now in science that are essentially
infrastructure projects and you know
they they build an infrastructure and
and conduits but they need to be
recognized and III think if more kids
grow up thinking of science is not
individual heroism at the laboratory
bench but see it as a team
a team sport I think this will be much
better now that's not to say that we
shouldn't shouldn't reward individual
merit time but but really I think we
were too far in the individualistic side
of things green and nothing on almost
nothing on the industry side is
individualistic like that oh everyone
was every other small team based for me
it was a culture shots and I was school
I mean school we were just had you know
Esther Wojcicki on the show and she's
doing this similar thing is like what
are you doing with these kids that are
all in their little bubbles in the rows
and stuff though this is ridiculous
have them collaborate have them share
ideas this is how you do it in industry
yeah yeah yeah and I mean that it's not
to say that industry does things
perfectly every you know every every
sphere has its challenges but one one
thing that in my experience it's done
very well and a really good experience
that I've had both at tier about
Sciences and at Novartis is this
team-based approach to science and and I
really like that and and there's
team-based approaches to science and
academia but it just has to be pushed
yeah I love how you use the word wedges
- that's a really good one wedges plus
blockchain for immutable decentralized
ledger of what scientific advances have
happened I mean if our collective
learning became became immutable on on a
decentralized ledger I think that'd be
fascinating to see who contributed to
which scientific block advancements out
into the fog of war where we don't know
and then you know we make that
advancement and then you can see that
this many these many grad students
partake partook and took you know 0.5
percent 1.7 percent of the wedges of the
project like that sounds very
interesting and a great future well I
mean it certainly could be great in some
ways I think we also have to be careful
about over measuring because there's
some things that defy measurement and
you know all that goes on in someone's
brain isn't capturable by blockchain at
least not yet so you know those of work
was worth 30 percent of the wedge and
yeah I think I think the arguments will
continue blockchain or not but seizures
but I think that that that's still
attempting to attach people to the work
that that they're doing now and what
it's going to do in the future and give
them credit for future derivatives of
their current work is important
absolutely it's a the inclusive state
holding system with with with the
scientific edge as well so that if you
put out a solid block out you can get
further scientific advances happening
from your block if the block is has has
lack of if it says that's rotten that is
it's horrible that's the worst thing to
do is contributor rotten block with
these perverse incentive systems I loose
I want to ask you do you know if
geopolitically how do other places in
the world handle the scientific
foundation of knowledge and incentive
structures so I'm not going to I won't
claim expertise where I don't have it I
can make a stab at that but with the
caveat that I'm more familiar with
universities set up in sort of the
Western tradition especially European
tradition and they are historically
constituted differently throughout the
world I mean if you look at the history
of many large countries in Asia many of
their university systems at different
points in their history served as
essentially training grounds for
officials and so but but then if you
look in the European tradition you're
looking at training grounds for clear X
and and so you know and clerics often
served as officials in you know because
there wasn't really much separation
between a kingdom and the church for you
know much of history so I think there's
some some overlaps but there's
definitely different flavors different
you know it's different budget sizes
there's a budget size as well I mean if
you look at the University of Beijing
yeah is you know it's the Harvard of
China if I might say so and that's where
Beijing genomics Institute
I believe but but it's you know the
these in terms of budgets countries with
large economies everywhere regardless of
their
you know their background and traditions
are erecting universities much like Duke
University with the same Crashers and
that's and so I I suspect that the issue
is global certainly but there's
different flavors and there's even
different different training
trajectories you know one one
interesting thing is to compare and
contrast european universities versus US
universities and the time that it takes
to get a doctoral agreed and and and it
looks quite a bit different actually
so there's even country to country
variances within the same overall
tradition at the end of the day we're
still agitating educating people based
on systems where we dress up in funny
robes once a year and you know that are
based on clerical garb so maybe maybe
it's time to get beyond that yeah you
know whatever ends up being this new
code that is deployed to maximize the
foundation of science to be innovated on
in the new incentive structures it's up
to us to push the conversations out
further have more scientists and more
artists and people out yeah this is the
crucial thing this is a lot of what your
new workers with bio captivate you know
the diversity of thinking is gonna make
better incentive structures exactly and
that and that starts with with how
people are connected to each other
people people put each other in boxes
and or they put themselves in boxes and
because of that they put each other in
boxes and all of humanity puts everyone
else in a box and people don't fit
neatly in boxes I think that most most
of your thoughtful viewers will have
long ago experienced that and and made
that observation and and so one is not
just a scientist you're human first and
and just as one isn't only an artist and
one is so many more things and so I
think that people need to need to break
out of their comfortable social
structures mine of course is a bunch of
nerdy like biological research
she's right I mean I could perfectly sit
among them and do nothing but talk about
biochemistry but where the improvements
to the world can be made and where
special insights can be made and where
people can find each other to help each
other when things like the whole Inga
scandal unfold is come when you bring
people together and you you have a
diversity of input and opinion then and
and it increases transparency to I
remember talking to Peter BOGO Sean
about who did it was a big part of the
hoax paper is exposing how the
scientific foundation of truth can be at
risk of of hoaxes and it can't be and if
we have to prevent that and one of the
ideas that I was passing along that it
would be great to see would be a really
fast and easy way for people to be able
to identify things that they thought
were malevolent data that weren't there
weren't been posting those up on you
know a top kind of like leaderboard
system of then of then of then people
that go to to do to validate is this
real is this not real
can we with drop from the foundation of
knowledge before it gets even more
rotten and so these types of thoughts
are interesting what are the top Rotten
incentive systems and how can we get rid
of those how can we have like a leader
board of the most rotten incentive
systems and the most creative new
incentive systems and have people
working towards those well it's a it's a
tough question that would take probably
hours to address but to your first point
there are types of software that can
detect manipulation of images in
scientific papers and manuscripts so if
people have been yeah playing with
playing with their images and and most
journals now require the submission of
unedited images for data of certain
types and I think that's been you know
very helpful and so you know that's
quasi automated or at least can be used
to flag things that are suspicious but
in the end
many things that look suspicious aren't
really it could be sloppiness it could
be just poor quality of data so it's
really hard to automate that without
talking to people and saying hey what
what am I seeing here and so I think
that's always going to be important now
journal structures can be set up to
incentivize open open journals so I you
know I I regret that for various reasons
so far I haven't published in too many
open journals but as I published
scientific works in the future I really
really am fond of EE life
you like Nobel laureate Randy Schekman
Berkeley pretty much pissed off the
whole science publishing industry in his
crusade to really build the Elife and
push it and push for open publishing and
there's a lot of good things about this
one of the neat things about Elife is
that the reviewers of the paper are not
anonymous to each other yeah so if
someone is deep-sixing someone else's
manuscript because it's a competitor you
know they can't get away with that and
so I think that those sorts of very
simple internet-enabled transparent you
know manipulations can be real can
really protect quality research and I
also think that the physics field and
the mathematics field has been much
better than biology and chemistry about
try uploading preprints so there are pre
submission drafts of papers okay so that
grabs priority for the overarching ideas
even if the experiments themselves
aren't fully baked you know maybe
they're suggestive but there's more
controls that need to be done and then
with the whole community able to comment
and help them out that that work gets
massaged into something really nicely
well controlled that after some number
of iterations finally gets submitted to
a journal of record for proper peer
review but in the interim one can get
their priority but still not be rushed
in terms of doing the experiments badly
to rush it into the journal so that's
that's you know that's another thing
and I think that
you know reviewers not being anonymous
to each other yeah that Schekman has
been pushing and successfully I think
and this this idea of you know
transparency of the data submitted and
pre submission of a draft really it
takes the pressure off and so I think
that's where things are headed and
there's any number of software platforms
that are held in startups that are
helping to make that happen so those are
some ideas and then there's there's
governmental ideas how do we fund how do
public how do how does tax money get
funneled to research and and how do we
distribute grants and I would say that
there should be far fewer grants per
reviewer so that they can take a deep
dive into those grants that's
interesting and that maybe we should
shift away from only prioritizing novel
research to prioritizing useful
extensions of less novel research but
still with a new twist and I I think
it's a subtle difference but yeah but
it's it's the difference between science
and engineering but you really need to
have both yeah to make the world work
and to make the world better yep you
know and this this also when you're
talking about the role of artificial
intelligence and the edge of science and
verifying some data this is very
interesting to see can potentially this
be an extension of our of us that helps
verify the scientific advancements that
we're making faster than we can that's a
very cool well I think one can check
certain types of data but for some of
these complex ideas that the data fit
within that framework I won't say I
won't be able to do it but it seems as
if there's subtlety there that is hard
to teach machines yes yeah so we'll see
where that goes I'm really interested in
in in terms of what we'll see in the
next ten or twenty or thirty years so
yes that's an exciting time to be alive
in all fields but in research science
especially yeah Lois we are extremely
grateful
that you stepped up and wrote this
because this when I was reading it I was
just I felt what you guys felt when you
were there and to me I felt trapped I
felt trapped like I didn't have a voice
and these are some of those are some of
the worst feelings to have is where you
can't speak up on behalf of science on
behalf of other people that that this is
so such an important story to be
communicating to prevent it from
happening again in the future to enrich
people's perception to be able to catch
it so we're really grateful that you
study you're most welcome and I mean I
wanted to keep the discussion here
uplifting and and I'm really
appreciative that you've you've guided
at that in that direction but I would
say that that the article about the
whole Inga scandal is a pretty sorted
tale and I know I won't say that the the
the bad people necessarily suffered in
the end so it's a morality tale but as
much as bad things happened as you point
out it's an opportunity to have really
valuable conversations about how do we
change this culture and and how can we
be more fair and how can we prevent this
[ __ ] from happening again amen and
and and in that so good has come a bit
correct
yeah we have we have our roots have dug
into a health so that our leaves can
blossom up to heaven exactly yes yes
Lewis thank you again so much for coming
on thank you so much Ellen yes the
challenging the perverse incentives and
science has been such fascinating
discussion everyone thank you so much
for tuning in we greatly appreciate you
we would love for you to check out and
read the full post that Lois put on
medium again that's the first link in
the bio you can also watch our first
interview at Lois that links in the bio
as well have more conversations with the
people around you in your communities in
a very neurodiverse settings and
Challenge some of these perverse
incentives think about how we can solve
them together build up on that
foundation of science is the most robust
thing that civilization has together and
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in our links are below
support us help us grow you shout out to
Ron Vargas for producing and directing
thank you very much and we love you
build your dreams execute build the
future we love you so much we'll see you
soon peace
[Music]
[Music]